so what's life like during the
apocalypse in a word extra hi hello it's
so good to see you again thanks for
having me it's so great having you in
and honestly Colin season 1 of daybreak
was so much fun wild huh
super wild Josh was just your everyday
average kid until this apocalypse
happened what was your favorite part
about playing this evolution of him in
this first season you know I think kind
of like what drew me to the project was
kind of that Josh is kind of two
personalities throughout the season we
get to see him in the pre apocalypse
it's just kind of an average kid with
you know not a whole lot going for him
not a lot of friends in Glendale and
then when the apocalypse happens I think
he kind of uses it as like a catalyst to
become the best version of himself to
kind of unlock the the Josh within I
guess and become you know the person he
always wanted to be on the outside we
also saw him wielding a sword for quite
a bit the season that's right he got
better better though you said that
better no you're exactly right but that
was kind of the most fun like I had to
know how to use the sword semi well in
order to keep it safe while doing kind
of some of the more awful sword wielding
so you know and there's no you know that
way I didn't whack myself or somebody
else or a crew member in the head on set
but yet learning the sword stuff was
really it was really great I hopefully
in the in the coming seasons Josh
becomes more of a sword master yeah I
think so yeah I think Wessel will whip
them into shape what was it like for you
getting to work with Matthew and and did
you fanboy at all absolutely I mean so
my favorite films growing up definitely
included wargames and Ferris Bueller's
Day Off
so getting to work with Matthew was
definitely a dream come true one of my
first conversations with Matthew what
was pretty funny we were sitting in our
little cash chairs waiting for them to
set up a new shot and Matt kind of just
looks over at me back and forth and
we're not saying anything he's like so I
heard you've been talking to camera and
I was like yeah man I have
and he's like what what you know how's
your how are you finding that what's
your experience been like and I said
it's been it's been great one of the
funny things about that is that you can
actually see yourself in the reflection
of a lens so that kind of before I could
even finish that Senate egos the fact
that you can see yourself in the lens I
was like yes like he's like I
experienced the same thing you just kind
of got to work through it you get past
it and kind of got to block it out of
your head
and so that was really like nice and
that made me feel comfortable to know
that he dealt with that too and that was
that I wasn't like alone and thinking oh
my gosh this is kind of difficult but
the fact that you got advice from Ferris
himself about the Ferris Bueller
inspired homages playing fair ception
that is exactly what it is what is one
thing that you learned about Matthew
that you think the fans would be
surprised to know oh okay
weird I have something off top I know
I'm like this usually takes something
like right you know like the the
backpack kid came out with like the
floss dance you know I'm talking about
so like I don't want to do it but
Matthew knows how to do it so he's
really good at it to dance he's like up
on the trends so I think people I think
people would be surprised to know that
he's got kids yes I think I think that
that's where he's learned it from I
would love to imagine that he in
st-pierre just are just like flossing in
there like New York apartment just like
chillin we of course no one loved you
from Supernatural so when you found out
that your love interest on Daybreak was
Sam Dean thought I was in so I was
stoked I I immediately proved like the
audition phase I I knew like oh my gosh
if if if I get this project and if like
the fans are gonna fan over the fact
that this name is so similar I mean it
would be so perfect so I mean in my head
I always like knew it as something that
was ironic and funny but the creators
and had no intention of like making that
joke or in Sophie Arana clay like if you
ask her she'll be like what's
supernatural after I told her she's like
wait Jared Padalecki from Gilmore Girls
okay
you're like oh yes like I look cool yeah
yeah she's like Dean I was like no Sam
she's like but he's like no but like
Dean episode 8 is so sensational it's
movie we get to see so many different
layers and really get to find out so
much about their relationship because we
had spent the first seven episodes just
thinking that they were this amazing
power couple who's trying to get back to
his girl yeah talk to me about filming
that episode and what really stood out
to you the most
ah man filming episode 8 was awesome we
were led by Kate Heron who directed that
she's amazing actually just messaged her
the day I was like I love you but no oh
my gosh so it was such a fun kind of
like two-man play that like being so if
you got to put on some of the things
that it really stuck out from like the
story wise that were really like kind of
fun and cute and and kind of almost
perfect in a way are like one of the my
favorite scenes the food scene where I'm
trying all the different foods and
what's so ironic about that scene is
like I'm a really picky eater now now
that I'm in my 20s I'm definitely trying
more things in depth I'm always open to
it like trying new foods and stuff but
in high school I I was like very I knew
what I liked and I stuck to it and if
like josh is really really similar that
way so it's kind of nice it was really
kind of fun to kind of poke fun at these
little things that were true to me I'm
sure to the character even another
little tidbit it's like every day after
work I would if I was really pressed for
time I would like call ahead food to
pick up and I would always get it from
the Cheesecake Factory like every single
day so much so that one of the lines I
think is like there's something for
everyone that she's cake factory and
that was something that I like in
defense of the Cheesecake Factory I said
on set and so they wrote it in the
script yeah it's like there's something
for everyone guys like how was the food
on set that day well it was so good yeah
it was really good we had it was all
brought in from a couple different
places and it was yeah some of it was
exactly what it was something wasn't it
wasn't wasn't what we said it was but it
it was really good I enjoyed all of it
what was it like getting to watch Sophie
dive into Sam's I don't wanna say
erratic behavior but when she was really
trying to push Josh to his
his limit and out of his comfort zone we
saw her put on the makeup in the Blazer
and like dance around the apartment what
was it like watching her go through that
I think it was so from Colin's
perspective it was so cool I mean I to
watch kind of so if he kind of I guess
take take the character into her own and
boss up a little bit like that was
really exciting I think it was a really
great moment for television I think it's
a great rule eight able moment for
people at home to just be able to be
like yes there we go
you know so I think that it was really
really cool and I think that Josh is
kind of sitting there like oh my gosh
what is what is happening to me right
now and I think it's really funny and
endearing to kind of just see like the
naivety on his face and kind of so
fierce am doing look this is me yeah
you're gonna have to accept me or not
mm-hmm well and it was so great because
like in the pool scene we see that Josh
is like I love you and you're trying to
figure out like does he feel like he has
to say that is it because we're in this
like teen drama where there's always a
love interest and then we really kind of
see that Sam spins it on on her head
what did you think about that when she
was like you don't know me well enough
to love me I think that I think that
Josh I think that it I think that
they're both right yeah yeah and that's
the thing is like they're just caught up
in and in a different moment they're not
living the same moment for Josh Sam
really is his love he loves love her but
it's his first love he's naive to the
way that the world works and the way
that relationships work and I think that
you know that's partly due to the way
that he was raised and partly due to the
fact that he is an enduring and kind guy
and that he doesn't know anything else
other than to just kind of tell someone
how they how he feels yeah
whereas Sam is going look you you've
only known me for this much this part of
my life this is very you know a very
finite amount of time how could you
possibly know me and in my entirety and
I think that's kind of the scope of what
she's trying to explain like you don't
get me yeah we haven't been together for
very long yeah you don't have a control
or ownership of me but I don't think for
Josh that's what he's looking for or
trying to get out of it yeah but I just
think they're just kind of maybe miss
communicating in the small I like that
you there they're both experiencing true
emotions but they're just not syncing up
yeah
exact I think that's and that's what it
was that's the way I read it yeah yeah
let's talk about that finale something
that you haven't been able to do for a
very long time no I know but the
episodes are out okay when you found out
that Josh was gonna be the one to
supposedly kill principal burr over your
thoughts ice priest oh yeah I thought it
was pretty epic you know obviously it's
a it's a group effort in the cereal
factory but you know to kind of be the
one to give that final stab very very
cool and what a what in a more fun way
to do it then kind of come back full
circle with failing at the beginning of
the season in with Terrance mark as
Ian's hand it was kind of nice to get
that final victory and and to really use
the kind of foreshadowing from the first
episode again with the nut allergy we
also give a shout out to the golf club
because all teams incredible we couldn't
have I feel like we got so lucky with
our cast it's their character perfect
they play it well and we had such a
great time working together we all loved
it like we all genuinely liked working
with each other yeah and hanging out and
stuff and that's why it's been so fun
and the end of season one Josh didn't
get the girl the girl got power that's
right what was your reaction to that
final scene you know I think I think
that from Josh's point of view it was it
was totally just caught off guard yes so
confused I think that we had the 80s
music playing yeah we were gonna have to
head back to Montrose grab the house no
I think that it was devastating I think
that ultimately you know he's not sure I
think the Josh's left uncertain as to
whether you know in the last few moments
post-school blast if Sam was using him
or not you know we did see that Sam was
really upset when he found out when she
found out that Josh was left with KJ but
now looking at the how it all turned out
I wonder you know if she was really how
and of course she was hurt but if she
was really that affected by it if she
knew this was if this was
kind of her plan all along you know we
don't know I know that's the thing I'm
like I don't want it cuz I they need us
fall in love with Sam Dean so well and I
don't want to think that she's now the
new Big Bad but it's looking like that
could be the case who knows like I said
earlier you never know the apocalypse
isn't always as it seems to be but at
the end of the day I think that Josh is
gonna be ready for whatever comes next
whether it's a battle whether it's a war
whether it's working towards becoming
allies whatever it is I know that Josh
will be able to you know combat that
challenge what have you heard about
season two just that everybody needs to
go watch the one first what would you
like to see if there is a second season
oh man I you know I'd love to see a lot
more battles I'd love to see a lot more
sword training you know or sword
battling I think that you know I think
that it's a lot of fun when we step away
from the dangers of an apocalypse for a
second and we kind of start to have a
little bit of fun with like the the
clothes or the cars or the the ghuli
kills yeah so I'd love to see some more
of that stuff I mean if the Walking Dead
can be on for ten seasons I'm pretty
sure that daybreak I think can get a
season 2 I think so too I you kidding me
I think we definitely have it so what's
life like in the apocalypse it's never
what you'd expect
[Music]